terney general Jeff sessions is expected
to face tough questions on Russia this
morning during an appearance before the
House Judiciary Committee sessions will
likely be asked about recently released
court documents in testimony they show
that he was told about meetings between
Trump campaign aides and Russian
interests now that information
contradicts his previous testimony Paula
Reid is on Capitol Hill with the latest
on this story hey Paula so what are
senators going to focus on today do you
think well Jeff Sessions you've worked
here for years but now on Capitol Hill
has really become a land mine for him as
new court documents contradict his
previous testimony before Congress
sessions has repeatedly testified that
he had no knowledge of any contacts
between the Trump campaign and Russia
but former Trump campaign aides Carter
Page and George papadopolis have
revealed that they both told sessions
about their contacts with Russia
Papadopoulos told the FBI that during
the campaign he suggested a meeting
between then candidate Trump and
Vladimir Putin in front of both Trump
and sessions and that sessions shut that
down now of course Jeff Sessions had to
recuse himself from the Russian
investigation for failing to disclose
his own contacts with the Russian
ambassador imagine they'll be fireworks
and Paula what about the Attorney
General now asking his prosecutors to
open up a new Russia probe that's right
the Justice Department is considering a
possible special prosecutor to look into
the Clinton Foundation and uranium one
that is a deal that was approved by the
Obama administration when a Russian
company purchased a Canadian mining
company with some uranium interests here
in the US now former Justice Department
officials tell me they believe that that
is also part of a long-term strategy to
discredit robert muller who was the head
of the FBI at the time and the president
has also called for an inquiry into
uranium one of course this this new
revelation will also give Republicans a
friendly line of Russia questioning for
the Attorney General today all right
Paula thank you so much